- All right.
We have one final heartwarming
story to share this hour.
This is what I'm liking.
I wanna tell you
about a game-changing school
generations in the making.
Super cool y'all.
25 years ago, a central Florida
couple was set to retire.
They had worked in education for decades
then they noticed how many
local kids were falling
through the cracks at school.
So instead of finishing up their careers,
they doubled down bought 12 acres of land,
and built a new school
specifically for underserved students.
It's rad.
Now their son has taken over as principal
and is continuing his parents' legacy
from the Caring and
Sharing Learning School.
Let's welcome everybody.
Principal Curtis and his wife,
the school's community
liaison, Tova watching on WNBW.
What's up y'all?
- Hey, Kelly.
- What an amazing family
y'all are a part of.
Oh my gosh.
So tell us more, Curtis,
about your parents and their vision.
- Well, my parents have been
in education for decades.
Like you said earlier,
my stepfather was the first
black tenured professor
in the college education at
the University of Florida.
And my mother was a
elementary school teacher
and when they were close to retirement,
they took some of their own funds
and they purchased some land
and took on the challenge of
starting a charter school.
So they started with 31 kids.
And in 2008, my lovely wife and I
took over and we now
currently have 250 kids.
- Oh my gosh, that's incredible.
So what makes this school different?
- Well, what makes us different
is we have high expectations for students.
We believe that every
student can be successful
and have big dreams.
We also have high parent involvement.
We make sure that our students know
that they can be the best student ever,
that they can be just as smart,
if not smarter than any other kid.
We have local community folks
that are always on campus,
speaking with kids about
career and life choices.
And then lastly,
we're really really big
on college exposure.
We presently have students registered
and enrolled at Florida A&M
University, NYU and Harvard.
- Also Kelly,
We have students that
participate in activities
that they may not be exposed to
for a fraction of a
cause, if not for free,
such as the performing arts,
etiquette classes, and field trips.
And for every student that
comes through our school
there's someone that works
here with a similar background,
whether that's being raised by
a single parent, grandparent,
and even great grandparents.
To us, this is more than just a school.
This is a community project
and a continuation of
Curtis's parents' legacy.
- It's an incredible legacy.
Thank you two so much for taking
the time to join us today.
Curtis and Tova, you're
doing amazing things.
I'm liking your post right now. Right?
That's...
- Thank you.
- Y'all look good.
It was a great picture.
That's not all though.
Our season long partner
pilot pen makers of G2
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing
the Caring and Sharing Learning School
a check for a thousand
dollars just to help out.
(audience cheers and claps)
- Thank you.
- Thank y'all so much.
Have a blessed day.
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Brendan Fraser, Jenny Slate,
Bernadette Lucas, and Lawrence Harris.
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.